buenas noches a la uai 2 sigue siendo el
líder opositor digamos acá en el país no
hizo formó su asamblea nacional de
manera clandestina en un lugar
clandestina donde no se conoció que
llamó a los diputados que lo acompañaron
desde el año 2015 en la asamblea
nacional que fue elegida en este momento
fueron 103 y ellos en general
instalaron esta nueva asamblea que dice
cuándo llevará durante un año más cuando
llamó a sus colegas opositores a que lo
acompañe durante este año más a que la
que vayan a hacer apoyo para cambiar
todo el problema que se necesita en
venezuela también insistió en que este
año
el abismo saldrá nuevamente del país y
hay otra parte de diputados los
compañeros de eso no dice que decidieron
apartarse de él en este momento diciendo
que no es legítima esta continuidad que
él ha dicho que va a hacer